et on est avec euh avec Thérèse argot
argot on dit OUI argot de nuit 35 jours
sans voir la
TER est-ce qu'on lu a déjà fait est-ce
j'ai des j'ai des Vanes son prénom mais
rarement son mon nom de famille non mais
vous l'avez jamais fait person vous
l'avez jamais fait c jamais Argo de nuit
non jamais c'est la première fois bravo
Cargo de Nuit j'adore bah voilà ce sera
gens sont focus sur le terraass
çaorsus c'est pas notre genre TR relou
de faire la vanne sur
c'estanichel aurait pu la faire mais
c'est unès grand fa merci de pas l'avoir
fag à la française merci ça va qu'est-ce
ça j'ai rien dit moi je suis content
mais tu as l'air tout tout il est sorti
fois
minutes on va revenir sur tout ce qui
s'est passé ch bien entendu qu'il
fallait pas louper mais Thérèse nous
parle elle est spécialiste
dentaire elle est sexologue en fait et
il y a des questions auprès des
chroniqueurs voilà qui pose problème
Gill Verdez notamment qui avec
saccompagne depuis maintenant combien de
temps on peut jamais dire parce que bon
ça pose problème un certain temps
malheureusement voilà en fait vous posez
la question à ma place quo en fait la
vie sexuelle de tout le monde c'est ça
ou pas du tout je pose le problème ok je
pose le
problème ou il a demandé en mariage lui
a dit pourquoi pas c'était a 6 ans
depuis on a toujours pas de réponse elle
s'est barrée avec un diamant à mon avis
elle a revendu elle a acheté une twingo
euh voilà pour non mais pour vous la
faire courte voilà voilà où on en est
aujourd'hui hein on va pas se raconter
d'histoire donc voilà aujourd'hui gin
Verdez a une question il est amoureux
sachez-le et euh sa question c'est une
question de quel type de vie quotidienne
vie quotidienneou quoi si tu dois aller
faire les courses
Thérèse ma compagne a souvent besoin
d'espace de
liberté alors ça commence je vais
poseroreore je vais poser la question
après à ma façon pose ta question et je
la poserai à ma façon évidemment je lui
accorde bien volontiers
néanmoins souvent elle me dit tiens
j'irais bien au Sénégal et je dis moi
aussi elle me dit non toute seule ou euh
je vais dîner avec des amis dis je peux
venir aussi non non non non donc voilà
euh comme ces espaces se répètent
dois-je m'inquiéter
Thérèse la traduction la traduction
euh ma meuf n'est pas là 5 jours sur
7 j'ai trouvé la semaine dernière encore
un WhatsApp qui me disait j'ai envie de
toi qui ne venait pas de moi dois-je
m'inquiéter à-t-elle un
cum dites la vérité non c'est un aïe Aï
aïe elle trche sa tête ouais ah ou quoi
qu'est-ce on s'inquiète un petit peu ah
thér est oui
bah quand
même tu le sais quand même tu vas
t'inquiéter à quel moment qu tu veux à
quel moment c'est ridicule maman c'est
vrai ça dev
ridicule on va quand même distinquer
deux choses on on a besoin d'avoir une
soirée avec ses Copin de temps en temps
très sain on a besoin de d'aller
respirer pour revenir avec une belle
énergie ok partir des vacances toute
seule et que ça reviennent souvent ou
partir plusieurs soirs par semaine ah
moi je m'inquiéterai ah ouais ah ou
s'inquiéter ah oui je m'inquièterai je
me dirais tiens en fait en quoi ma
présence elle t'empêche de te sentir
bien pouro tuas pas envie d'être avec
moi je
penseésol la question oui on peut poser
la question disant pourquoi est-ce que
tu préfères que je ne vienne pas avec
toi et ah bah va dire parce que tu es
lourd ou parce que tu
Saou la répse a la réponse ça ve dire
qu' fa quand
mêmeinqu tu
t'r çaempêche pas l'amour mais voir
comment être plus léger avec elle plus
agré
la voilà merci beaucoup ah ouais j'ai ma
réponse est plein d'espoir merci
beaucoup il y a un petit sujet et
parfois justement ça pe être un peu une
fuite de la relation d'aller à droite à
gauche au lieu d'aller voir le vrai
sujet qui qu' vous trouve lourd ben
comment est-ce qu'on peut faire pour que
ce soit plus sympa entre
vous non pas du tout à ce stade là il
faut qu'elle fasse quoi non non non non
là c'est juste un petit signal d'alerte
est-ce que tu vas comprendre qu'il y a
un problème il faut comprendre
qu' oup des signau quand
même te cache pas quand au bout de 6 ans
tu as beaucoup de signau à un moment
faut savoir se mettre sur la bande d'arr
d'urgence tu sais
mais enfin elle est encore là elle est
encore là elle est pas vraiment là elle
est encore là quand tu vois ton mec une
fois par mois tu es pas encore là qu tu
vois un mec une fois par mois parce que
tuasas un problème de plomberie qui
vient à la maison juste pour t'enlever
le non mais le tuyau non mais c'est vrai
quce tu fais ce weekend par exemple tu
avec ta meuf
euh oui pas tout le weekend mais ouais
dimanche on est ensemble vous allez
faire quoimanche soir euh théâtre et
restaurant théâtre et restaurant le
dimanche après-midi comme les
yeuvesouais c'est vrai matiner ou alors
quand tu vas au théâtre le dimanche
après-midi avec ta meuf c'est que
normalement il te reste de semaines à VI
non c'est TR ch si je te le dis arrête
arrête th arrête de dire que tout es
chou arrête un peu mais sans rigoler il
va voir une pièce de théâtre je connais
ouais vas TR
coups les décors sont P tu
péter
mon mari vite
fuillonsban que signifie cette
mascarade non mais sans déconner frère
tu vas avir Boeing Boeing non mais sans
déconner non mais frère c'est quoi cette
racera le dimanche après-midi au théâtre
frère il va pleuvoir rassera dans la
Twingo et bim et ça pleut pour peu que
tu tombes sur Bernard Montiel sur RFM
bonjour perd bonjour bonjour davidid
Est-ce que tu votre
père comm il pleut tu arriv au théâtre
tu sais pas où te garer frère il arrive
ta as que des
yeux avec
son comme tout le
monde c'est l'autre connard de la
télé non mais sans déconner mais c'est
quoi
c'est quoi cette vie cette vie de merde
après tu vas aller au restaurant tu vas
all au bist romain je connais frérot
avec la mousse au chocolat volonté o
tout le monde cracher dessus je connais
j'adore romain j'adore frère frère il
t'ont ramené la mousse au chocolat
d'une c'est un truc c'est pas une mousse
au chocolat c'est un jacuzzi
frèreas la cuillère d'un gars
toi en plus il reste un dentier ti
vasy mais c'est
ça oh là
là quelle race la M chocolat tu trouves
des DS en ord
ça ou ils la font plus je sais la font
plus il font plus est-ce que vous voulez
CER une petite info de culture générale
sur le théâtre pas qu'on est rigoler là
bah oui mais on peut allier drôlerie et
culture mais pas avec
toi vasy ouais ah à quoi correspondent
les actes au théâtre pourquoi il y a des
plusieurs actes comme ça avec à chaque
fois le rideau qui se
sa que dans le temps il av pas
d'électricité donc on jouit avec des
bougies et donc c'est chaque Act
correspond à la durée de vie d'une
bougie on romp on ferma le bureau on
remettait des bougies et on recommença à
notre voilà c'est intéressant
dir franchement c'est intéressant moi je
vais le
retenir bra Jean-Michel je
t'ael il y a Bernard qui m'a
[Applaudissements]
nard bravo Bernard
ne manquez pas bernardtiel sur RFM c'est
tous les dimanches je peux vous dire si
vous êtes fragile vraiment au niveau si
vous êtes fragile au niveau de la tête
on va dire il vous achève hein écoutez
la dernière fois j'adore mais bon c'est
des interviews je peux vous dire il y va
à fond dernière foisbl la dernière fois
il recevait Charlotte de Turk j'éta
comme ça première première question
Charlotte comme le gâteau
ah ouais quand
même ah ouais quand même le gars il y va
allez nous répondre à cette question
dans un instant pour le moment c'est
parti c'est les yeux couleurs Montal
avec Ed fa un peu
trop sans décon je peux te dire tu sors
de ça je peux dire tu sors de ça tu es
comme ça frère alors oui qu' a des
questions parce qu'elle doit partir Tha
pas que ça à non
plus qu'est-ce qu'il y a oui bah oui une
question à à deux étages alors un mon
mon 1 est-ce que combler sa copine au
lit bien au-delà de ses espérances peut
finalement et paradoxalement devenir un
problème dans le couple et deux est-ce
que vous êtes est-ce que ça vous décède
est-ce que ça est-ce que ça est-ce que
ça vous est est-ce que ça vous est
excusez-moi c'est important est-ce que
est-ce que ça vous est déjà
arrivé est-ce que ça vous est déjà
arrivé foudre sur un plateau télévision
et c'est oui voilà mon
portable
[Applaudissements]
par Frère
l'élocution sans déconner frérot que Ken
comme tu
[Applaudissements]
parles ah ou franchement
s'il vous plaît je vais
demander là dans le public on descend de
étages ça va merci m
gison pire que mes lycéen quoi c'est
pire que M lé quo non mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que
ce quoi tu trouves qu'on fout trop le
dawa je trouve qu'on fout trop
le franchement vous avez des questions
pour
alors lui maintenant je t'explique lui
il est arrivé en début d'année frère il
était comme ça il avit des pull jusque
là maintenant il met des chemises j'ai
fait des
com le gars il se prend pour un il fait
des questions maintenant avec épaule
témon ah ouais j'ai une
question frère il fait il fait des
maintenant on é pasau témon on ép
témonme oui moi j'ai une question frère
le gars il est arrivé frère il était en
col roulé frère là
vendit onimession dans uneor
maintenant il est arrivé il
est
salut c'est une questionement c'est une
question très personnelle pourquoi vous
avez voulu devenir
sexologue qu'on à
F me c'est quoi cette bande de char là
frère mais sans déconner celu il fa des
enquêtes maintenant sur ma vie finir
journal du dans can pas rglementaire
qu' chos arrête un peu pourquoi tu lu
demandes ça frère je va demander moi
alors n tuas pas demandé à pouras demand
à
moi mais s parce que ça pour être ta
fille
[Rires]
connard sans déconner j'en ai marre
m'intéresse de savoir mais répondez pas
ça le du merci th une vraie question
comme on est une émission mec moi j'ai
des gars à faire rentrer
en bien sympa non mais bon entre l'utre
c'est comme
tu veux bien la poser pour moi la
question mais frère quoi j'ai un dîner
aussi là vous av un dîner ou bah
amenez-le avec vous tiens vousz pas
dîner avec
Thérèse vous avez quoi quoi j'ai
quelqu'un qui m'attend mais il va venir
avec vous pas qu' sera content e les
mecs vous êtes vraiment des charau mais
c'est
insortable c'est viarriver par avec lui
par
avec non mais sans déconnait quoi si on
peut plus poser des infos on arrête
l'émission vas-y pose ta question là
pourquoi vasy vas-y alors moi je voulais
savoir thérè on parle souvent de donc de
télé parce qu'on est émission de média
est-ce qu'il faut avoir une télévision
dans sa chambre à coucher ou c'est
catastrophique pour le sexe ah c'est
catastrophique pour le sexe évidemment
je suis désolé si vous voulez si vous
voulez avoir une vie sexuelle épanouie
on enlève la télé on enlève les écrans
et vous allez voir que votre viite
sexuelle va repartir comme ça et la tout
natalité en France va repartir en flash
donc non non la télé les écran pas dans
la chambre à coucher on fait plein
d'autres choses que regarder la télé je
suis
d'accord
la télé et quand même les gens ont
beaucoup de problèmes de libido ils
sentent une paire de de désir sexuel
commence par enlever les écrans on voit
ce qui se passe et après mais on regarde
des films d'auteur dans la
chambre calme-toi calme-toi oui est-ce
qu'il y a des choses qu'on peut manger
pour améliorer notre sexualité des
aliments ben non alors mais pas de
piment tu vas avir des éories non
maisend mais F aliments à quelle heure
votre dinîner là c'est à quelle heure
vot dîner mais c'est quelle heure pouss
au fur à mesure euh non mais en fait je
suis bien sûr
[Rires]
que pousser parce qu'on B ça c'est quoi
c'est à quelle heure le dîner mon dîner
ah oui bah oui B céit à 19h
là tu des avec qui à 19h
frère alors je t'explique le mec qui d
avec toi à 19h il a une femme il veut
manger avant
frèreex tu connais frère tuas déjà vu un
mec qui dit où il a 82 piges
frère
non d mais attends 19h tu fais dîner non
pas dîner mais je toute ma
Vieh suspect c'est suspect on s'en fout
fait ce qu'elle veut on av 10 person
demandé c'est vrai que tu demandes juste
pour la séquence à quelle heure il est
son dîner c'est bon mais ouiarrê bon
laissezla tranquille
[Applaudissements]
là trou à il est très troubl pas dire
trou donc bref la
nourriture mais simplement d'être en
bonne santé quoi de sentir bien dès
qu'on est c'est pour dire des conneries
pareilles excusez-moi c'est pour la
nourriture ça ser juste à être en bonne
santé je bar
maisia non mais on parle évidmentiments
on dit aphrodisiaqu et CETA mais ce qui
est intéressant quand même c'est c'est
quand même de savoir que quand on sent
qu'on a une paire d'énergie sexuelle on
peut aller aussi voir comment est-ce
qu'on s'alimente comment d santé
générale c'est vrai c'est important ce
que je dis il y a plein de gens qui ont
des peres de sexualité et tout ça ils
ont ils ont une libido qui baisse parce
qu'en fait ils s'alimentent mal il d'eau
par de toi et il mange plus Raon non
mais c'est vrai c'est important tout est
li au c'est B au
BE
[Applaudissements]
excusez-nous il est tellement lourd sans
déconner il est tellement
lour une question
intelligentez qui a une question
intelligente là oh vous savez comment ça
se passe dans les classes quand on
intervient sur ces sujets question je
dis comme ça vous voyez à quoi ça
ressemble quand on intervient sur ces
sujets auprès des collégi c'est la même
chose est-ce qu'il y a une fréquence
normale pour tu nous fais chier
arrête sors tu me fais
[Applaudissements]
chierz dans
son alors oui
question à quel moment il faut
s'inquiéter lorsqu'un couple ne fait
plus l'amour au bout de combien de temps
il faut qu'il s'inquiète 2 he 2 he 2 he
vous voulez la vraie la vraie réponse ou
la réponse un peu hypocrite la
rép ça dépend pour chacun mais moi je
pense pas du tout moi je pense que il
faut quand même avoir un rythme régulier
et c'est quoi c'est quoi un rythme
régulier c'est quoi le rythme régulier
moi je pense que au moins une à
plusieurs fois par semaine
heusementou que en VO on est d'accord ok
oui parce que normalement la réponse de
siècle comme
Dani c'est quoi la
réponse
Laé dire ça dépend pour chacun à chacun
a donner son rythme et Cera c'est vrai
plus moi je pense pas trop je pense que
quand même c'est important aussi ça fait
parti de la vie et quand il y a une
disparition des relations sexuelles on
peut aussi s'inquiéter on peut aller se
consulter dire pourquoi on a pas envie
de faire l'amour Varou
ouais il parti
l'autre on va vous poser d'autres
questions qui vient je veux une bonne
question question a que des questions de
merde c'est quoi votre question à vous
[Applaudissements]
question pas
question h intéressant j'ai pas de
question moi j'ai pas il a toutes les
réponses déjà c'est fini moi arrê c'est
fini mais c'est hyper triste non non
c'est pas TR on peut en parler s'il vous
plaît j'ai assez de problème comme ça on
essaie de raviver le flamme mais bon
rideau on enchaîne on va faire entrer